the full extent of the damage
russia's war cannot yet be known but
western powers are hoping inflicting
economic pain will push president putin
to reverse his course
hi welcome to another cold fusion video
where i cover anything in science
technology business or history
as you all know there's a conflict going
on between russia and ukraine it's a
terrible situation and i do hope there
can be a peaceful resolution
for this video i particularly want to
talk about some of the sanctions that
have been placed on russia
a group of nations barred russian banks
from the swift system and also levied
some other sanctions against their
central bank
we'll see while the financial sanctions
on russia may have unintended
consequences that may affect you and i
so stay tuned for that
you are watching cold fusion tv
as russian forces began their attack
ukraine's foreign minister made angry
calls for russia to be banned from swift
but world leaders appeared divided later
we'll see why
but in the time since they've decided to
act
the united states britain and the
european union announced that selected
russian banks will be removed from swift
the society for worldwide international
financial telecommunications or swift
for short is a vital piece of the
plumbing that connects the world's banks
if you've ever sent money overseas then
you've used the swift payment system
there are more than 11 000 global swift
member institutions and around 42
million messages are sent through the
network daily
before swift transaction messages had to
be written on the computer manually the
messages would describe the transaction
in sentences which were then interpreted
and then carried out by the receiver
as you could imagine human error became
a factor
being frustrated with this six banks in
luxembourg and paris started a new
messaging network which would become the
swift company in 1973.
swift is an organization it has a ceo
and gains revenues by fees from banks
joining and also charging other fees per
message based on the type of message and
the length
today it secures trillions of dollars in
flows of trade and investment between
200 countries
so that brings us up to now
what do these russian sanctions really
entail
in february of 2022 after russia's
invasion of ukraine leaders from the uk
eu united states and canada announced
that selected banks in russia would be
disconnected from swift
a spokesperson for swift stated that the
move would be a collective benefit to
the global community they stated the
decision to impose sanctions were solely
in the hand of government bodies and
applicable
legislators so what will these sanctions
do exactly
according to eu commission president
ursula vunderlin cutting banks off will
stop them from conducting most of their
financial transactions worldwide and
effectively block russian exports and
imports end quote
but it's not all as it seems as royce's
reports quote getting kicked out of
swift doesn't make transactions
impossible it makes them much more
difficult and it increases transaction
costs significantly
julia friedlander senior fellow at the
atlantic council states banks can also
resort to alternative systems and even
communicate via email to send payment
instructions
bloomberg's in-house energy expert
xavier blas notes that the german
government said that the ban would only
affect russian banks that were already
sanctioned in other words it's an action
that really has no teeth it may purely
be political just to soothe populist
anger
so the swift ban wasn't as big a deal as
it was made out to be at first but the
thing that is really crippling russia at
the moment is the central bank sanctions
in conjunction with the swift ban the
united states banned transactions with
the russian central bank that means no
transactions in dollars euros pounds or
yen
currently the russian central bank has
630 billion dollars in reserves but the
reserves aren't unsure they're mostly
with other institutions overseas the
move to block the russian central bank
from international transactions was done
to stop them from attempting to bring
assets into russia the purpose was both
to weaken the russian currency and make
financing more difficult but as time has
gone on since those days it seems that
there might be unintended consequences
[Music]
cutting russia's central bank out of the
global economy isn't going to come
without some consequences
according to the european commission
russia is the eu's fifth largest trading
partner the eastern nation has supplied
much machinery and transport equipment
chemicals and manufacturing goods to the
west the sanctions could come back and
hurt europe's economy germany may be the
hardest hit with a large percentage of
energy coming from russia but the risks
go far beyond europe however it could
impact the united states and the rest of
the world
the price of oil is also rapidly spiking
and oil is an input cost to almost
everything from the transportation of
goods to the actual manufacturing of
them uh absolutely there is nothing more
fundamental to costs than the cost of
energy and basically it's the start of
uh pretty much everything and so you're
right not just motorists um all sorts of
businesses will see their costs rise
ultimately that means uh consumers will
see their prices rise
so we are talking quite a challenge and
it comes atop existing challenges uh for
inflation
with rising geopolitical tensions russia
somewhat has seen this coming and has
taken steps to reduce their dependence
on the us dollar
for one over the years their central
bank has sold a lot of u.s dollar
reserves and bought gold
moreover they've developed their own
banking messaging system the system of
the bank of russia or spfs
this new system is opening up to mostly
belarusian banks and already has over
399 institutions russia is in talks with
china to join their system too
china themselves also have their own
system called the cross border interbank
payment system or cips
so at this point you might start to see
what's happening here the world may be
splitting into two payment systems
one system for friends of the united
states and western allies and another
system for those who are wary of the
united states
according to an analyst who wrote in
bloomberg quote one could even imagine a
future in which rival nations turn
similar financial weapons against the
united states
continuing on with unintended
consequences more broadly this all in
the future could lead to a decline of
the us dollar as the reserve currency
currently all oil payments are done in
u.s dollars every country needs oil so
this keeps the demand for the dollar
high and gives the united states a lot
of leverage geopolitically this is often
referred to as the petrodollar system
it's been keeping the united states in
charge of the world economy since 1971.
since russia is the world's second
largest oil producer if they sold oil
for gold it would be the first time oil
has been sold in something else besides
the us dollar by a major player
a spokesman for goldman sachs stated
quote overuse of dollar sanctions could
compel other actors to try and replace
dollar transactions
also in a very recent federal reserve
meeting federal reserve chairman jerome
powell recently admitted that there
could be more than one reserve currency
we do benefit from being the reserve
currency for
the main reserve currency for the world
and that really is because we have open
capital accounts in the rule of law over
time
the question is if if some want to move
away from the dollar what will be the
effect on us
i don't think it's something you would
feel right away over time
they would have to create an
ecosystem economic ecosystem whereby
another currency becomes
uh
you know a better a better currency for
them to use
[Music]
you know what we can do is we can make
the dollar the most attractive currency
by continuing to have the rule of law
and and open capital accounts and and
make it an attractive place for people
to invest and to use in their businesses
there wouldn't be any short-term effect
of that over time though
um you know it would it would uh it
would i suppose it would diminish our
our status as the reserve currency it's
also possible to have more than one
large reserve currency
so it's not really clear
so obviously it's not something that's
going to happen tomorrow but it's a
trend that started and could continue in
the future
jp morgan and other wall street firms
councilled washington against some of
the russian sanctions saying that it
could have far-reaching faller that
could hurt the global economy and
undermine the purpose of the penalties
already the sanctions have hit russia's
local economy hard their currency the
ruble has fallen off a cliff now being
worth less than the currency in the
mobile game clash of clans
locals have been rushing to atms to
withdraw us dollars running to stores to
buy food and anything that isn't nailed
down
all of this in an attempt to save some
of their purchasing power
[Music]
since thursday everyone has been running
between atms to redraw cash someone gets
lucky others not so lucky the last time
the russian ruble collapsed was in 1998
the fall in the currency caused a
complicated chain of events that
eventually led to the collapse of the
loan firm long-term capital management
the collapse of this firm almost took
down the entire global economy but it
was bailed out to the tune of four
billion dollars just in time
today russia could default on hundreds
of billions of dollars worth of bonds as
roughly half of their reserves have been
frozen in the foreign exchange markets
if they can't pay their debts experts
warn it could once again lead to a
cascading chain of events
as the old saying goes if you owe the
bank a million dollars that's your
problem but if you owe the bank a
billion dollars that's their problem
in other areas russia has the highest
wheat exports in the world this has made
the price of wheat absolutely sore
ukraine produces half the world's neon
gas which is critical for the
manufacturing of semiconductors
so there's a lot of things in flux at
the moment and no one really knows how
this is going to play out
moscow supplies 40 of europe's natural
gas prices on the continent have
increased by a third since thursday when
the invasion began
russia is the world's largest wheat
exporter prices last year were already
31 percent higher than in 2020 that's
according to the un's food and
agriculture agency economists fear they
could climb even higher
as for what to do financially i
definitely can't advise you but as i
said in the video how money is created
it might be worth taking some time to
study hard assets and the sectors that
you could see benefiting from such
scenarios for example wheat and gold
have risen in price substantially
recently
so in conclusion perhaps world leaders
may not have thought through the effects
of cutting russia from the global
economy but also perhaps they do know
what they're doing and nothing will
happen right now no one knows as the
world painfully learns in 2008 the
modern global economy is extremely
complex and impossibly integrated it's
impossible for any one person or body to
predict what's going to happen but
everyone can agree that the economic
global risks have increased it's really
imposed severe trade sanctions we've
imposed heavily financial sanctions but
we've not been willing to go after the
oil and gas because
europe gets over 40 percent of its gas
from russia
russia is still one of the three largest
oil producers in the world and so it is
it would be destructive both especially
to europe but also to the u.s to put
those kinds of sanctions in place and so
we've held back on that to try to
minimize the effect on the world but we
shouldn't kid ourselves there's going to
be a cost here to all of us oil is
already over a hundred dollars a barrel
europeans are paying five or eight times
as much for natural gas as americans are
paying for it and and yes there are
consequences they're going to be cost to
what we're doing
now in saying all of this i have to make
it clear that the other option of doing
absolutely nothing wasn't valid actions
of some kind had to be taken against
putin to send as a signal all in all if
anything can be learned it's that war
helps no one whether it's in ukraine
afghanistan iraq syria israel or
palestine war only leads to more human
suffering i really do hope that an
agreement can be reached to the current
conflict i don't like to see anyone
suffering
for you that's watching i at least hope
that this episode provided you with some
insight into what's going on financially
and was helpful to you
in the next episode we'll take a look at
something a bit more positive a new
technology that's helping paraplegics
walk again so don't worry there's still
some good stuff going on in the world
if you want to discuss today's topic in
more detail you can head on over to the
cold fusion discord but please be
respectful
if you want more cold fusion i co-host a
podcast called through the web where i
talk about these topics in more depth
follow my instagram for podcast clips
and other fun stuff if you want to see
these episodes early and ad free the
nebula streaming platform is the place
to do that to listen to the audio
versions of these episodes they're on
spotify and other streaming platforms
and lastly i'm also on twitter
so thanks for watching my name is tagogo
and you've been watching cold fusion and
i'll catch you again soon for the next
episode
cheers guys
have a good one
[Music]
[Music]
cold fusion
it's new thinking